oh Kelvin is just non-stop still getting
logged whoa Lake nope that's rocks
all right I think we should build our
camp here because it's got a nice good
vantage point it feels naturally
defensible from this Alcove and it's got
a fresh water supply and access to the
rest of the island I'll work on the uh
Forest side defenses and then you work
on the beach side are you saying the
side I'm currently building the stone
wall on why are there why there oh God
don't look over there
what this is how you throw oh
my God
we're under attack don't worry Mark I'll
help you murder this person no questions
asked there's a lot more of these guys
wow my wall is
hi ladies
so is she supposed to have free
appendages I think so yeah uh oh there's
a wall there's a wall there the wall is
complete why did you put one Spike on
the log wall that was an accident you
gotta be honest that was not I can't oh
God guys guys
[Music]
run over so you're saying like the wall
is really worthwhile
hey everybody
I don't like him
oh guys help help don't worry Mark Holly
I'll help oh if I see his toes help Mark
I missed
hey there you go
look at that he was better than me in
every way so you're saying is Bob and I
should invite him to join cow I don't
know where Cal went I gotta be honest
never worked down a raw fish I feel
great I'm just gonna catch and eat a raw
fish real quick to feel better about
what yeah these guys are crawling around
throwing our logs they are and I don't
appreciate that I gotta be honest is
Kelvin alive
I think he's okay I don't know
he seems alive I'm gonna hide behind the
stone wall I think that's really the
play is one of you ominously moaning
directly to my right is that one of you
guys
running around yeah weapons okay I
really would appreciate if one of you
could be that person and I turned to my
red and it's one of you guys playing a
hilarious joke it is not I mean uh
oh
my hair myself
you hear yourself yeah I hear myself
through your thing because you're wrong
yeah it takes up it's like our system is
rounded you know I appreciate the new
system and its ability to have more
free-form construction but I also miss
the guidance of knowing how to build a
Gatehouse
it's a little janky still pretty cool
oh someone's barking is that you wait
um
I'm assuming these spikes are gonna help
them not climb right over it
that's my goal that seems like a good
theory honestly
so I'm gonna side with you on this one
we are a United Team we are
we once Ward upon each other but those
were times of old everything changed
when okay we're trapped on this island
with a bunch of psychopaths can we call
them the Fire Nation are items
individual or uh like are they out in
the world because there was cloth and
rope under this rock over here I don't
know if you guys can get it separately
or not
uh I got that already so I think they're
oh cool so they're individualized I
think what where
[Music]
um
over here it was something under a rock
yeah yeah by the end of the water thingy
that we were hanging out by there's a ah
and there's skeletons just at the bottom
yeah they're fine uh Bob someone just
ran right at you from our wall oh so he
did oh he's coming I'm coming spikes
helped at all he's very tough I got him
I got him I got him I got him I got him
check this oh yeah oh God
oh he's still alive oh there let's fix
that
that's good
give me that Arrow back those are
surprisingly valuable oh here yeah and
I'll give it to you
how do I where is it so Mark these
spikes don't stop I wasn't talking to
you I was talking to him oh never mind
do you think they'll stop them from
climbing the wall oh that's that's what
they're for
okay so yeah of course why why would
they not that's really the question
Calvin
Kelvin
in a while
yeah oh he's over here he's being
harassed oh
Alvin
all right um so yeah wait I just got I
gotta say this wall
looking pretty good
it looks good but does it does it do
anything or yes or oh no it doesn't do
nothing problem okay that's what it
seemed like
it doesn't
do well we have quite a few gaps in our
walls right now so it's really hard to
judge them any of them at the moment
yeah but if you just like look at the
wall they just like
walk right over it basically yeah pretty
much
so it's not ideal
I wonder if there's a way you can put
sharp things on top of the stone walls
probs
probs yeah
ooh I'm going to do something
tubular dude are you gonna do it tubular
kid oh guys we made walls but this whole
time this whole time we could have been
making fences wait fences
that better than wall
I have no idea does it is it seem better
than wall
I don't know is it like I don't know
what the fence is how do you make a re
how do you make a fire I'm so confused
right now you take sticks you put them
on the ground
you tell Kelvin make fire okay you take
sticks play on the ground
and then you just light them yep on fire
or is it
okay sponsored by Coca-Cola are we why
would we I would be surprised okay
usually you know when you're sponsored I
just want to make sure it's been a while
we've been in this forest for a long
time yeah I'm kind of thirsty for a
Coca-Cola wink wink I mean maybe we
could get sponsored on our hit podcast
distractible we're very official and
very very well known
I would like that though I don't like
Coke's usually pretty family friendly
which is kind of anti-us
we're not anti-anything what are you
talking about oh I mean we [__] kill
a lot
oh oh well I I mean yeah but that
doesn't sound I don't guess who made a
log sled
nice but can I hold rocks too or just
logs it logs
hey guys I think it might be about to
rain
yes
wow
can that be a new recurring character on
distracted
predicting the current weather
oh God it was not raining when I had the
ideation
that it might rain did you hear the pr
the ominous Thunderclap I did as I saw
the rain and then your prediction so
yeah so somebody's oh chuckle chuckle
yep
yeah well it was not so funny is it well
it was funny here's some logs I'm
delivering logs for you I I made a pile
of firewood next to the fire for fire
purposes I
so we got that going for us
um how can we um
what what is this why is this gappy I
don't know man
what's gappy
that's right are you having them get
more logs yeah I wish he could use oh
God there's a guy with a banjo he's got
a banjo
Angry Bird
wow he is much larger than you he is a
motor he is much larger than you
that is a motor
wait a minute quick button to bring out
your spear you can equip it in your
backpack too oh he's so tall
are you telling Calvin to get logged
because I may have just started quite a
long intensive project oh God oh God oh
God I'm being in the air I've been oh
I'm in the air hey Mark I'm gonna revive
you while Wade Keeps Us Alive all right
that's a great idea how do I equip the
spear again
ah
oh he's down
is he dead
sort of running or is that do we leave
it or okay
are any of us alive I know we all got
blown
we got motor blown
where did I just wake up and respawn at
I don't like it yeah I don't know Bob if
you're up while you're up can you uh
touch us no no I'm not I'm
um
ah it's one of this situation I see
right can you guys get to me in time
what why are you why why do you get the
easy way because you guys gave up faster
so we're quitters and oh hey what's up
Mark I'm going for it
I can't move you gotta get your knife oh
I see I'm out here
later nerd Mark hurry wait don't worry
I'm on the way oh don't worry I'm three
quarters dead can you beat the timer oh
well I'm trying oh I'm trying is Mark a
good gamer let's find out oh no I don't
know there's a lot of rocks I could
gather on the way oh I think it's about
to rain
uh it already is stupid and now it
doesn't really dumb of you
[Laughter]
it's a good idea it's a good thing those
guys have a camp so close to our camp
it's really convenient yeah very
convenient I hope this doesn't become a
constant reoccurring thing where we're
fighting them off really hope
I hope you're fine you're fine
you suck that is quite a log intensive
project yeah I know we're getting there
how many logs
like a lot ooh is this really worth our
log budget yeah Kelvin where's Kelvin
Calvin
Calvin oh how do I get my backpack back
where did I die
oh you didn't pick up your backpack oh
no
no wait but but I have it oh dude what
are you doing there you walked into
where am I am no I was going up against
the December this body where is my
backpack it's back where you spawned
oh it's the exclamation point back where
we I see well
good luck okay
good luck I guess if I die again I'll
spawn right back where the backpack was
and that was super unclear this guy has
a sweet skin pouch
yeah I got one of them is that good that
is made of skin
do I is that useful for something or not
you open it how do you open it I can't
open it because I don't have a backpack
apparently to YouTube you gotta look at
it
Google get it hello Camp of bad guys I
think Kelvin is lost I'm gonna go try to
get him can I like destroy their camp
that'd be nice I can oh
do it you got this destroy the cap
destroy the camp battle stop that'll
stop him from messing with us dude
that's gonna piss him off and they'll
probably leave forever because they're
so bad about it someone's trying to hurt
me
this point why is Kelvin pointing behind
me ominously
oh
elvin's gone
Elven ran away Kelvin literally ran away
Kelvin he's going really fast away
Kelvin is spooked
Kelvin is moving so fast does Kelvin
know something that
the rest of us might want to be clued in
on Kelvin looks a little scared
trying to get him to follow me
I think I just got to get him back to
Camp guys I don't know there's a throne
over here guys I'm gonna destroy the
throne yeah destroy the throne
oh actually why would I destroy it when
I can just sit in it
that seems like just an oh hello flesh
chair
I gotta be honest I think these guys
might be gardening wrong
yeah what are they doing they have a big
planter but it's all full of Bones and
goop Ah that's it just feels nice the
fertilizer
maybe oh you know what you might be onto
something
man these guys are really close to our
camp and really uh problematic
um they're just getting more and more in
number and they're running towards
Kelvin oh my God
don't worry guys I just went all Legend
of Zelda all up on their potteries oh
God
I know they're gonna be mad
you're right Mark I'm trying to be
hey that's all we can ever ask oh man
guys uh this is getting dicier by the
second Wade uh uh what are you doing
work on this rock wall oh my God
why what's up they're trying to kill
Calvin they down Calvin
well that will not actually just this
one guy
[Music]
did we get him or oh [__] okay all right
up and Adam all right I threw a rock at
him too just just
tell them to suck ass good good
no I don't want you to follow me what
happened to my log uh uh
sled
Kelvin probably here Bob I'll help you
I'm gonna I'm gonna just like I'm just
gonna cut down a bunch of trees and you
you get them we're gonna get through
this sounds good we're gonna get through
this
where's your sled Mark did it disappear
I don't know where the sled when it's
gone that's kind of disappointing it is
[Applause]
into that
oh my skin pouch had a candy why is
Kelvin Gathering rocks
uh
he doesn't gather rocks that you need
anyway he gathers the useless kind of
rocks oh what a [__] so it was you wait
of course it was me yeah so are you
gonna apologize
no I literally said it was me apologize
come here why would I stop telling him
to do things or tell him to do the right
things get logs and
uh you don't want him we don't want him
to bring him to where he is
having him follow you to a better
location yeah I'm working on it I'm
working on it let's not I'm not thinking
it I'm not thinking him you're out
thinking I don't know if you are out
thinking the Mindless AI That's helping
us oh dude I am out thinking well what
if we could get the uh that lady the
three-legged lady to help as well then
we'd have two people dude chicken with
Gallop that's so effortlessly around
yeah can you imagine where is she
I think you scared her away with your
antics what do you mean scared her away
with my answers my Antics are hilarious
fantastic I mean exactly what I said it
again by the way as the person who's won
the most episodes are distractible I
think we can all agree that I have the
best Antics I don't think that's even
one of the most because Bob gave you
wins you didn't earn yeah but you I only
won the least because you took him away
so it evens out yeah that was my right
yeah well it was just you are allowed to
he was a lot yeah you are allowed to
death I'm not denying that he was but
currently as it stands I am the most
prolific and probably big penis winner
well I think we all know actually you
know what I don't think all three of us
have seen all three of our penises
you're right
I think no I think true
only some of us have seen some of our
penises so
yeah I am waiting to hear someone
dispute my claim and I will I'm waiting
to see your penises I will text you
momentarily all right I'll text you
momentarily well not you I'm gonna turn
my phone off wait no turn on your phone
wait if you turn it off that you'll just
know what's waiting for you the next
time you power that bad boy up
you can't escape it Wade what has
happened all that for on like eBay or
something oh no we made extra half logs
that we don't need for anything
distractible dick pic what's the going
Market
why is the log holder on the wrong side
of the wall just
shut up
never mind just shut up just just mind
your own business
God damn you asking questions
I will never shut my hole shut your damn
hole I'm not going to you guys shut my
hole you can shut up I sent you a text
wait that'll probably shut your hole
Yeah I opened my text and you'll see how
shut my hole is
I'm not opening that no I mean then shut
your hole that that dude just dived for
you Bob
I he's I'm we're just playing the game
oh he smacked me I'm in pain and peril
well don't
be such a crybaby I guess would be my I
feel like I I feel like I took that
thing we're coming together pain and
Peril
marks you uh I'm fine this is fine doors
this beer what are you doing I'm trying
to gather sticks I'm one gentle spear
away from Death be very quiet there's
something wrong guys I found more
if I pick up the Rocks a lot a lot am I
different rocks I don't know what that
means like the rocks by the beach I see
a bunch of those big Flat Rocks by the
beach if I pick them up is that going to
do you good
uh
and I tried to pick up they're like logs
you have to you have to carry them like
logs you can't put them in your backpack
unless this guy buy these logs good
sledded well he didn't really work get
slinged
me bro I like how we're fully committed
to this build even though I have no
preference of if this is even a thing
that's worth doing in any way whatsoever
I mean I'm sure it's worth our time yeah
I don't know what it is but I believe in
you way more than I believe in Wade's
wall
so hateful of walls you dude your wall
is in the worst spot wadrian's wall over
here yeah you know you guys started
building your [__] around my wall not
the other way around just remember that
I built it first
and I want you to know something the
Cornerstone of my wall is actually Rock
so I was building with rock before you
were even building with rock wait it
sounds like we agree that sounds good
rocks you could take and oh Mark these
half logs you're right yeah look at you
you're so smart Mark uh yeah
yeah yeah
collapsing and I tested it you get my
sleep thank you for testing that right
near the end of the build I appreciate
that you're welcome
as good as building a thing oh you're so
close no no dude I can pick up literally
all of these rocks they're new fresh
beautiful rocks for me no sleep
no
sleep just wait the lean two is almost
done just give me a sec yeah just give
him a second anyway I'm helping out with
your dumb wall all right I don't know
what this buys us I have we have a lean
two now so
we can be we can
be in here so yeah so now I can stand in
here as I go to sleep out here no not
quite no you can't you can't
sleep actually sleep in the lean too no
but you can stand in there sort of what
I thought
the idea was gonna be uh sleep
uh hang on I'm catching some fish maybe
oh okay sleep hang on I really need this
fish
oh no I really I really don't need these
fish apparently I I own fish already
yeah they're probably rotten by No Sleep
hey what's up well they're cooked so
they're fine I cooked them and hey guys
I have some LED light bulbs that fish
was rotten
that's great sleep oh man uh hang on wow
yeah that that was awful ladies lady
friend oh if only we'd slept no she
wouldn't be here if we'd slept whoa oh
hey ladies don't sleep with us not like
that whoa she's getting real close uh
whoa ma'am would you like to
okay sleep what why did you have your
spear out you idiot
it's always out put it away sleep yeah
let's sleep hey she's still here she
watched over us yeah hey lady uh back
our Guardian sleep
yeah just like that uh I'm helping with
your wall
thank you what happens if I cook rotten
fish is that okay uh yeah
tell us how it turns out
I mean if they cook it it can't be
rotten anymore right so that's good math
why did Sleeping only get me like three
quarters of my sleep meter sleep more
I'm fully slept you must have slept bad
yeah sleep better dude
because I was thirsty when I went to
sleep
oh uh kelvin's over here
a bad way no bad drowning
I'll save you oh that's the good
drowning these rocks are heavy man I
gotta get really close as water to be
able to drink it I know you gotta
basically be an inch above the water and
then you just start sucking and it goes
in there yeah
and like a Whirlpool water spout
situation up to my mouth Yep this guy
knows what's up yeah
oh you think I haven't drank before
Calvin's so spooked he's not helping
anymore he doesn't get anything
but I don't know how to kill him
whoa wait uh uh with kindness maybe I
mean it's true he's right he's not wrong
he's right he's not wrong I think he's
wrong
he's right and not wrong Mark the fish
is burning I just want you to know does
it burn is that a thing I I don't know I
took I took one off accidentally that
was not cooked yet and the other one I
took off is cooked so I'm saying I
helped no I don't want to though
this one was not cooked this is not
cooked
it's broad it's still raw
eat the rice for that would you guys
like to help me gather I mean I I feel
like I did say that
well I didn't understand that you took
my cooked fish in place of raw fish and
I did not take your cooked fish I took
my cooked fish I feel like that was my
cooked fish because I put my fish on
before you put it on some sleeping
bloody cultists
probably we should murder them I guess
yeah we should murder them
okay
how do we get some traps I want to get
some traps these guys are annoying
uh B for book
I can't possibly help me uh f for
yourself what lyxian censor that man
oh sorry f for funny Mark sorry I mean
to say that yourself word Lucian uh make
it sound like he's complimenting me in
the best way why do these Stones
sometimes not Place completely together
you need to like finish a chain of them
for them to like count as a wall oh I
see I see
I'm tired of building the wall you know
we don't all get to just sit around and
make Kelvin do stuff were you trying to
make Kelvin do stuff he was but he
failed at it I did all right well I'm
gonna get some traps and change the
veracity of what I said still pretty
good veracity
thank you voracious use of the word
harassment whoa what's a fly swatter
trap oh this looks fun
I don't know what this is probably a
thing that we need yeah okay just so you
know traps are going on the ground you
gotta Be watchful watch your watch your
back this trap's gonna be on the ground
okay where and just look around
Where can I
where it's gonna be traps where all over
the place spiders
I have yet to see spiders well then
you're just not looking
Mark spider
yeah man
there's a lot of logs over here dead
spider I killed the spider
are we cool don't worry guys I killed
spider I don't know which way is the
right orientation for this but I'm down
for it Mark uh if you're putting traps
down I just want you to know you care if
I have some of your supplies I've worn
our lady friend because thank you
huh she comes and goes you don't want
your skull oh you're right you're right
oh
yeah this seems like a good spot for a
trap they like the prowl right here
hey come back here
I have stuff for printers now
printers ow why what are you doing why
are you doing it what are you doing oh
that's nothing
why are you doing this
I don't I I'm not doing anything I'm
just standing here for a while I was
very high on health I had actually does
that actually injure you yes of course
it enters me
about well how many rocks did the face
does it take to kill you that's my
question
it needs to be answered hey you're in
Calvin's way I'm about to Wiley Coyote
your ass you just stay right there I
found evidence of aliens oh you think
you're clever huh
oh yeah I'll help you we'll wait till I
get some sticks there you go
yeah yes you wait you wait buddy just
you wait pal oh okay
yeah just you wait what is that is it
Mark I I gotta say Mark I don't I don't
know that this does anything yeah just
you wait buddy oh I'm gonna get you you
got me oh no not yet
here Mark I made your trap more
dangerous how'd you do that I made it be
a fire
what look
I don't know if that did that whoa
I it doesn't do anything it just does
that but it doesn't hurt you or anything
I don't I don't know
the most dangerous part is the little
fire
all right look I wait why was Kevin on
the ground wait why was guys Calvin what
do you mean he's just standing here for
me he's on the ground he just got up
Calvin
hang on I'm just using your trap Mark
I'm trying to figure out what it does
exactly oh it's deadly watch out for it
yeah no I I just yeah set it up right
and then uh-huh it is called the fly
swatter trap so I think that should
indicate it's deadliness because it
flies uh swatters against many things
yes oh it's a trap to catch fly swatters
but you can use those against the Flies
this is like a very roundabout way to
doing things but you know you seem like
a roundabout way to be a bad friend
thank you anyway I'm gathering logs
cool cool
all right wait where you make the logs
not you're helping me with the Rocks I
was done with that I got bored oh well
I'm so sorry our defenses are boring to
you yeah well mine are better look how
nice this is starting to look look how
nice and beautiful and big my rock wall
is getting
huh how why
was did you shoot me with an arrow no no
why are you walking towards me with an
ax I'm not walking towards you with
anything whoa okay you need to be fair
last time I threw it it ended up in that
[Applause]
let's go yeah
I know why are you being like this you
bounced it off of Mark into the thing
look mark it just bounced this right off
that's what you write give me my Spears
back there you go
take this I missed thank you no give me
my Spears
laughs
what's this epic throw watch this epic
throw right in the NOG
good night that's what you get can you
help me out out why yeah I'll get you I
just try to I'm trying to toss them into
the thing
I'm trying to go get logs why would you
put them back in the it's almost like
you try to help trying to actually play
this game you were in the way of that I
swear to God
what is your objective what is your
objective honestly I don't know then
stop for doing it and let me go get logs
let me throw logs at you what's so
complicated about this it belongs at me
when I'm down over there collecting logs
okay can I get a ride
no see now that we're here we can
purposefully throw logs all we want
oh I'm I'm
from you I'm crawling away no I saved
you don't worry about it I'm crawling
away all right don't make me declare war
it's terrifying when he does that I
gotta be honest yes you don't want me at
my War
stop doing anything oh God you've made
it horribly unstable
I feel like this is just YouTube being
obtuse
how dare you I'm a cute I thought you
were making your wall
damn I need more rock
we'll go get more rocks then
it's just wait can we what if we can we
like tip this thing over to like dump it
out I don't think so
foreign
you guys just amuse yourselves with my
log sled I guess I'm trying to get them
off I don't understand what's happening
you if you throw them they go right to
it the beef bear Ohio public school
didn't really teach us how to get them
off very well it's true hey Mark I
emptied your log sled all right cool
thanks all right so looking in the book
looking in the big old book the various
traps we can make there's really nothing
why can we make no deadly traps
oh my God Calvin Kevin Calvin what are
we doing man
he just landed into the pile of locks
did he ruin everything
he's moving logs from over there to over
here
um
great good job
go go go
okay please stop
hi the [__] do you see what he's doing
yeah he's uh he's really
really making us proud
stop buddy bro friend
he's the one is best
keep it up Calvin
he puts his pants on one leg at a time
like everyone else okay
it is I do actually have to go
unfortunately we've accomplished so much
yeah right he does
listen
I've got this rock wall like four levels
high now
should we save and sleep or just save I
guess I guess I'll just save then
sleep I could sleep sleep you never
it's fine I'll save
but I'm not happy about it good boy did
you just say good boy to me oh God
you grew up
don't ever do that again against it
how are you holding that bench uh like a
man
you're right
uh look now look at the Leaning too that
we're doing this is a great lean-to
um
I feel like we've really thrived
spot him
uh come here friend wow
uh headshot